[Música]
frente a las puertas del 10 de downing
Street los manifestantes esperan el gran
momento
profesores bomberos ferroviarios Todos
quieren un cambio y buscan presionar al
Primer Ministro sunat
el antiguo líder de la oposición y
figura de la izquierda inglesa Jeremy
corvin apoya a los sindicalistas
algo está cambiando en el país la gente
está harta de 12 años de austeridad de
descenso de la calidad de vida caída de
los salarios y escasa inversión en
servicios públicos
esto es un grito desde el corazón creo
que vamos a ver un mes o dos de intenso
movimiento social y el gobierno tendrá
que dar marcha atrás
el país entra en un invierno de fuertes
protestas un movimiento social que no se
veía desde los años 80 con margaret
thatcher el costo de la vida está por
las nubes y todos los británicos se ven
afectados en 2022 el precio del gas
subió casi un 130%, el de la
electricidad un 65% y el del azúcar casi
un 40%. Estas son las cifras oficiales
pero para algunos el precio de la
calefacción sea más que triplicado en el
área de betnal Green en el issn de
Londres la cliente era de Mark apoya los
manifestantes es importante que la gente
pueda hacer huelga están alzando su voz
porque están hartos Ese es su último y
se ven obligados a hacerlo los apoyos
totalmente
Mark nota que la gente gasta menos
las autoridades dicen que la inflación
es del 10% pero Honestamente creo que es
más bien del 40 o 50% en el mayorista
cada caja cuesta 4 o 5 libras más eso es
mucho entonces tengo que subir mis
precios en Bristol ciudad del suroeste
de Inglaterra Tom es profesor de
secundaria enseña historia aquí los
precios de la vivienda se han disparado
en los últimos años según Tom la crisis
financiera lo cambió todo
2008 fue el punto de inflexión hasta
entonces los salarios en el sector
público era más bien Buenos
algunos de nuestros colegas un poco
mayores en sus 50 podían comprarse una
casa hace 20 años cuando costaban mucho
menos y su poder adquisitivo era mejor
pero para los profesores que ahora
tienen 20 30 o incluso 40 años es mucho
más difícil
tome y su familia llegan a fin de mes
gracias a que el salario de su esposa
como profesor Universitaria es pero para
muchos de sus colegas las situaciones
diferentes muchos dejan la enseñanza o
protestan las manifestaciones nos
abrieron los ojos cambiaron la vida de
muchos muchos trabajadores luchan por
sobrevivir no pueden permitirse la
calefacción en sus casas los niños van a
la escuela sin haber comido porque no
hay comida en casa
Esta es la realidad de millones de
británicos
en primera línea de esta revuelta social
están los hospitales con el National
Head System la Joya de la corona de
Reino Unido gratuito y al borde del
colapso según estudios oficiales en el
sistema sanitario británico hay más de
10.000 puestos de trabajo sin cubrir el
brexit también complicó la situación se
estima que alrededor de 4.000 médicos
optaron por no ir a trabajar al Reino
Unido desde que salió de la Unión
Europea el nhs vive la mayor huelga de
su historia Steve lleva 27 años
recorriendo Londres en su ambulancia no
me metí en este trabajo para hacer
huelgas sino para ayudar a pero la falta
de financiamiento los bajos aumentos
salariales han hecho que haya decenas de
miles de puestos de trabajos sin cubrir
en el nhs los tiempos de espera para
acceder a las ambulancias son cada vez
mayores
y este invierno la espera también se
hace muy larga en los saturados
hospitales
el real colegio de médicos dice que cada
semana mueren 500 personas debido a los
largos tiempos de espera tenemos
historias terribles horribles de
pacientes que esperan en la cama del
hospital durante 10 12 horas es
inadmisible
es duro saber que uno va a esperar horas
y horas que el estado del paciente puede
empeorar y que no hay nada que uno pueda
hacer para ayudarlo
el día comienza y una llamada entra
inmediatamente
tenemos trabajo
alguien perdió el conocimiento Steve y
evie están listos como siempre los
equipos constantemente solicitados piden
más recursos para seguir salvando vidas
los políticos concuerdan en la necesidad
de reformar el nhs
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el río támesis separa a Westminster el
corazón del Poder del hospital Santo
Tomás
todos los pacientes tienen una opinión
sobre el sistema sanitario
Es una lástima que no tengan otra forma
de hacerse Escuchar
creo que las enfermeras no son
respetadas que se les paga poco por la
cantidad de trabajo que realizan y por
su esfuerzo personal
pero la gente tiene que pagar la salud
No es gratis miren otros países
Yo viví en Estados Unidos y cada uno
tiene que pagar lo suyo
un taxi llama nuestra atención
al igual que tantos otros trabajadores
las enfermeras salen a las calles
[Aplausos]
los aumentos salariales propuestos por
el gobierno de risa y sunac no fueron
convincentes muchos transeúntes aplauden
o tocan la bocina en señal de apoyo
[Música]
el invierno de las protestas continúa y
crece
[Aplausos]